materials supplied by microsoft
corporation may be used for internal
review analysis or research only any
editing reproduction publication
reblogged public showing internet or
public display is forbidden and may
violate copyright law
thank you very much so I'm a new
lecturer at the University of Edinburgh
so before I actually start talking about
this topic I thought I briefly mentioned
some the other stuff I'm doing mostly
because I'm trying to advertise my
general existence and potentially find
collaborators we'll see one of the
projects that I'm finishing up with the
Indiana University at the moment is on
viewer privacy so this is a screenshot
from linkedin linkedin allows reciprocal
information between people who view
profiles of people who own profile so if
you've ever been on linkedin it sends
you a million-one emails some of those
emails include information like who's
viewed your profile so whenever we see
reciprocal information of that type
typically it causes some level of
chilling effects so people are less
willing to interact with the profile if
they know the interaction will be closed
so one of the research projects I was
looking at that I had a graduate student
s at Indiana University that was from
Saudi Arabia was very interested in the
use of whatsapp particular the privacy
settings in Saudi Arabia this is really
interesting in terms of concerns
expectations and how people maintain
social groups particularly since
whatsapp seems to have this opinion that
if you've gotten on whatsapp you must be
a friend with every other person on
what's up and hopefully goes and uploads
your entire contact list and
automatically friends you with everyone
which is fine back when it was just your
friends but if you're a woman inside of
Saudi Arabia you cannot actually move
between two points without effectively a
cab which means that frequently you have
people in your phonebook that are in
fact cab drivers it's very common
situation and so you end up actually
sharing your phone number which is the
unique identifiers on what's up with a
large number of people so we did a
survey looking at the concerns and
expectations and how people are managing
these sorts of issues on whatsapp and so
some interesting stuff there I just
started to edinboro but we're looking at
some things so one of them is security
of health apps health apps are horrific
we designed for security most of it's
because security is hard to do quite
frankly it's it's really hard to get
right it is really hot right
hard to get right for everyone every
from an end user all the way down to a
system administrator to a developer it's
just hard across the board and so what
can we do as far as HDI to try and make
some of the building of apps easier make
them make more sense for people who
maybe don't have a four-year degree
we're in the age where apparently
everyone can code according to social
media and that's terrifying for security
how do we make it a little bit less
terrifying and similarly there's this
question of how do you do system
administration system administrators or
users to we seem to feel that we can
throw harder with problems at them but
they're also still human and so what can
we do to support their understanding of
networks and support their management of
security all right but back to the the
primary topic of this talk which is the
human factors of software updates so I
actually I did this research before this
comment came out just make a point there
but this from XKCD urgent critical
update available details fixes an issue
that was causing random laptop
electrical fires this update require
restarting your computer remind me later
this is classic and most people identify
it with it pretty well I like to think
of software updates as unsolved solved
problems so we sometimes get a problem
for example the heart heartbleed
incident from actually I'm not sure how
long ago it is now but it like just over
a year we had 600,000 vulnerable servers
to hardly good news though it's not a
massive hole that we found it's actually
very patchable so what's the first thing
we do and find a patch of what we patch
it and we release the update uh one
month later we had 300,000 vulnerable
servers it's awesome we got rid of half
the vulnerable servers ah two months
later still 300,000 vulnerable servers
and by one year later it's now two
hundred thousand this is a solved
problem this is not a mystery it's not
even hard to fix and yet we are still
looking at a third of the servers online
who have not patched it
so is it Linux fuckability uh actually
don't I think it's linux in fact servers
is the key thing I don't it's SSL
openssl feels good the basement this
isn't when this isn't characteristic of
Windows updates is right now and I'm
going to actually bounce across Windows
Update versus other types of updates
this one for instance targets mostly
windows this is a study of 10,000
windows users done somewhere around 2012
looking across 13 countries that's a fun
number so what you're looking at here is
not everybody really installs updates
and it's really interesting to see this
graph in light of the research i'll talk
to you later because first off that's an
enormous number of people who aren't
updating but if you look at the Delta
between that and the three updates later
people are installing the updates not
everybody clearly but there is a delay
and a huge network and what's also
really interesting if you look at this
table is the list of different
applications yep so they're taking these
numbers and that first as a java right
so a bunch of these things got spun
installed as a result of their
harassment that you get through the
update process right also the US
government said nasty things about
gelatin so it's out of the ones that
still had it running how many of them
were still untouched I presume that
sounded so in a blue hat lecture he did
on the doctor for the described this as
we call people up on the phone and said
will you please install this exe that
collects all this data this is being one
type of data that was collected as
pre-2012 I think Microsoft collects on
this data more internally now they just
looked at the the exe files one of the
observations that was made at this
year's security and privacy is that a
lot of a lot of systems have multiple
versions of the same piece of software
installed installed by multiple other
pieces of software so things like Adobe
Reader sometimes has like four versions
and so if you try to update w if you're
the best user out there you're updating
right away you still might not have
updated all the adobe readers and that
also
I think ties a little bit into this but
I think the question is also what what
matters I mean there's vulnerability and
so you look at gen gen gen pop for you
look at general population let's assume
that these echoes statistics then you
look at the botnet what's the case
what's the case there I think you're
almost sitting in a level below where
I'm at because I I do agree that it's
there's a difference between exploitable
and not but we see a lot of things so
it's door Demetrius has some work in
this looking at the manual different
versions and how to actually cause
exploits to variant versions so just
because it's not currently being
exploited doesn't necessarily mean it
can't be um and he has no okay the
impact of a different things at the best
stories there is widely and contracted
miss of these things that is widely so
just you know they're not comparable one
to one in some sense wonderful this is
not the same sponge about that is
there's a little piece in fact speed of
it yeah well the more high-level work
okay so this is just me trying to
demonstrate that these are the some of
the top pieces of software that are
actually being attacked use malicious
software riders are very aware that
there's a lot of people who aren't
updating Java and they're very aware
that Java is buggy and we see what other
things I mean windows this very common
piece of software which also causes it
to be a common source of attack this is
probably not necessary for this crowd
but I do this talk in front of a lot of
people with a wide variety so we're
going to a really high level and what
the heck is an update and why do you
need one I get the feeling you kind of
know this but at the very high level an
update is just something that changes a
piece of software you used to have piece
of software a you now have place of
software be this is an example of this
happening very visually on itunes on
what this means for security is if you
have a computer and the computer has a
bunch of files installed our different
programs installed on it some of those
programs can't have whole
rules or bugs or problems if you feed in
a malicious piece of if you use that
program which may not even be
internet-facing to open another file
that file can be used to trick the
system into doing something malicious
i'm using the holes an update at least
the security ones are designed to patch
the holes and provide this problem the
one time I try to do this lecture in
front of a media arts people I realized
that I desperately needed that slide but
we are more concerned with this question
which is why aren't people updating
software I'm going to talk about two
studies that were done this is an
interview study which is what I'm going
to start with and then I later did a
follow-up survey of a much larger number
of people in this study what we did was
we brought in a bunch of students from
Michigan State University we ran custom
powershell script on their machines to
pull down the logs we had them do a
short survey in the middle of the lab
and then we did a about a 40 minute
interview with them the participants
were 27 of them their aged 21 257 uh we
actually add a good female to male split
note that they are all graduate students
we tried to keep the technical ones out
but that is bias but don't mistake that
for them being security conscious out of
the 15 had at least one security problem
of some varying types 06 head either not
installed or disabled their antivirus to
it turned their firewalls off seven them
head either turned off or limited user
account control and six of them had
either turned off or limited Windows
Update ah just to make sure we all
understand how Windows Update works it
actually happens in about three phases
most of this talk is going to focus on
Windows 7 because that's what the most
common version of Windows that happened
at the time of this study so this graph
is about windows 7 windows 8 and 10 work
it similarly but not quite the same so
what happens here is a starting with
this blue box windows just goes and
automatically checks for updates it
pulls the updates down and notifies the
end user users get upset when you reboot
their computer
so it tries to give the user a time
period during which they can decide
whether or not they want to update the
software which is what this green dotted
boxes this is optional the user once
they're showing notification gets to
just think about it for about 24 hours
until 3am for windows seven anyway at
which point the system decides that the
stuff really needs to get installed
automatically installs it and then if
necessary reboots the computer this
progression is important because some
users never hit the red box they see the
notification they install the update
they didn't even know it's possible to
have it forced some users never notice
that the notification and only see the
red box and therefore assume that it
just always installs and forces them to
reboot their computer it's a common
source of confusion amongst users is a
lot calls because it does take into
account above the machine is on or not
yes it does take it out into account on
Windows Update is what I've been broadly
referring to is a triggered event so it
it automatically updates when a set of
conditions have been made in Windows 7
the primary condition is 3am I don't
know i have an experiment with laptops
enough to answer this question I've had
enough anecdotal evidence to tell you
that users are suspicious that it
updates even when it's not plugged in
that said I can't tell you whether
they're accurate or not they just tell
me that it does this and kills their
battery so I haven't had that
opportunity to experimentation so for
this study we saw most people sitting on
this standard default which is just
automatic update for participants had
set it to notify them about an update
but not automatically install it into a
disabled it entirely I'm going to start
talking briefly about the log file
analysis but I won't go into too much
depth on it but we're really interested
in two questions so our users
installing updates and our users
installing updates quickly so this is
just a graph of the number of months the
user has owned the computer against the
number of updates that have been
installed this is a very rough metric
the green dots are everybody who has
automatic updates install or set up so
they're automatically installing the
yellow dots are all users that have set
to notify and the people who turned it
off have no updates installed so they're
just not on this graph middle E this is
a little bit eyeballing but we're not
seeing in large difference between
people who are notifying and people who
are just automatically saying it which
switches us to the question of okay if
they are installing it what is the time
to patch look like researches focus yes
ah not mr. all right we do see a much
wider time to patch the top of that box
is sitting about 20 days and I mean the
automatic people both there are less of
them and so that naturally tries to
bring the box down but we're seeing them
do it faster and what's also interesting
is if you break them out so what you're
looking at here is these are all
individual participants this is based
update 30 days is the middle line if you
can't read it they're sorted by their
median update time some of the people
over on the far right like this bar
never uses this laptop and so you're
seeing a wide time to patch it's also
interesting that you're seeing for the
people who do notify they're almost
always skewed upward this is actually
falling very much in language what you
would expect they're being notified
about an update sometimes they stall it
right away sometimes they delay it for a
while because they have more opportunity
to delay than the people who have the
automatic installations so the short
version we're getting out of this graph
is people are installing the updates if
given the option they are delaying the
updates but they do
actually get around to install and if we
switch over to looking at this a little
bit more from the survey perspective so
what people gave us as far as structured
answers don't about that so we asked
them what do you think windows updates
doing on your machine on your individual
computer so do you think it's going to
notify you before it install stuff do
you think it's going to notify you after
it has installed the updates do you
think it does both of these two things
the correct answer is it does do both
depending on the settings so the people
in the green boxes are correct there's
some kind of good and Newt bad news here
the good news is that the people who had
changed their settings to notify knew
they had done it so they were there
fully aware that they were in charge of
installing these things it was not going
to automatically install and they did
know that oddly a lot of people think
that it's notifying them before it
installs the update and that it's
actually automatically installing the
update so if we kind of go back to this
diagram member i said that some people
never encounter one box to the other
because they either miss it or they
don't see it a lot of people feel that
that we need to reboot right now to
finish installing your updates dialogue
that they had on windows 7 was it asking
to upstate update right then and that
leads the situation where we see 20
users who feel that is in fact their
responsibility to decide when the
updates will be installed so okay again
this is not really news right users
don't necessarily identify this what's
interesting is we see it happen across
more than just microsoft windows so this
is Joba we were collecting the version
information from several different
applications java came up very
frequently in the interviews as this
thing that was really confusing they
didn't understand in the survey we asked
them you know are you it doesn't auto
check for updates does it auto install
the update is it not automatic at all
and do you just not have it installed
and we compared that to what was
actually going on on their computer
about the same story here what's
interesting is that the biggest number
here 14 feel that is their job to update
they know the system is not going to
automatically update they are fully
aware that updating can only happen when
they hit the box and yet they're not
updating and so there's a lot of
potential reasoning behind why they're
not updating but with this this graph
and the prior one basically says that
you are aware that they are the
gatekeepers to making this decision and
yet they're deciding not to make it and
so why what's actually causing that so
we did interviews here I'm going to talk
to them really fast because I did
slightly more depth in a study which I'm
going to talk to next the high level
outcomes of this work is that people
really didn't like that user interface
changing very quickly this is primarily
mentioned in terms of iTunes which had
decided to change the user interface
right before our study and this they'd
hear from their friends that this change
was going to happen and they go find how
to disable the automatic updates because
they didn't want their music to vanish
which is the way they would describe it
they didn't know what some software was
so I have a lot of great quotes by Java
what is a java why do I need a Java i
deleted the Java and then something else
broke and software that's functioning
right now so there's an American term
that if it ain't broke don't fix it and
so a lot of users had this opinion that
if they went out to go fix this thing
that was working right now it was just
going to get worse I mean it was good
now they didn't need better and if they
went fix it it was going to get worse so
this was Adobe Reader all over I have a
quote from participants basically it's
reading PDF files why does it need to
update why indeed so the outcome of that
led to this question of what factors do
users consider when deciding to update
or not is
so in order to ask this we turn to a
survey because we wanted wider set than
37 graduate students to get a better
sense so we use Mechanical Turk with
this standard limitations that apply
namely that these are slightly more
technically savvy users when it comes to
interacting with the internet we asked
them if they felt that they ask other
people for help and if they feel that
other people ask them for help as a
measurement of skill I can tell you they
all think that other people ask them for
help and they never ask anyone according
to them with some minor exceptions so we
got 307 responses so the way this survey
worked is first we ask them some
demographics questions and then we just
ask them to tell us a story about a
software update event we tried to be
very general but we made it very clear
that they could tell us a good story a
bad story just tell us about something
to happen to you involving the software
updates we then ask them 17 follow-up
questions about that experience
including whether they consider to be a
positive or negative experience how they
became aware of the update why they did
or did not install this particular piece
of software what made them decision and
then after that we asked them to tell us
the opposite of what they told us before
so if they told us a positive story
before we asked them if they could
please tell us a negative story we
correctly predicted that most of them
would tell us- stories beforehand about
two-thirds decided to select a negative
story and we wanted to also understand
what makes an update a positive
experience not just a negative one so
I'm going to focus on some of the high
level results of that this is actually
still being written up in a paper that
hopefully will get submitted soon
there's a lot of interesting things here
that aren't going to be necessary
presented one of the key ones is the
dropout during the process of updating
so we think of updating frequently as
just that one dialogue but as I'll time
to talk about it as I go through these
updating is in fact an enormous process
starting from becoming aware of the
update after you do various preparations
in advance of the update getting locked
down in a specific
okay Shin well it does the update and
then dealing with some of the
after-effects of it and you'll kind of
see that in some of the discussion here
the four things that I think are really
interesting coming out of this though is
first off that reputation really matters
people are really concerned about
whether or not it's worth the bother of
updating resource consumption with a
major concern and then one of the
interesting if somewhat minor findings
is this whole conflation between updates
and viruses so we'll go through those
people research updates a shocking
number of people research updates this
is by no means a large percentage of my
dataset we're looking at close to Julie
ten or fifteen percent but they are
still talking a lot about updating and
asking their friends asking the internet
looking at reviews looking up these kind
of reviews generally trying to figure
out what does this thing do what's it
gonna do I mean stuff like from this guy
reading my text you can keep the bugs so
people are really concerned about these
sorts of things and what they were
mostly looking for when they were
looking at recommendations are changes
to features so what people are concerned
about this hey when people who
self-select to publish these reviews are
concerned about this but in a general
setting what percentage of people or
indeed concerned about these these kinds
of issues especially the non-technical
one speech as you mention and Turk well
it gets it gets you some bread was a
mixed bag it is definitely mixed bag the
other key thing to note here is we're
not actually looking at percentage of
update offense we're looking at things
that are most salient to end users so
when I ask you for a story what is the
story you think of first it's a decent
representation of that it's a horrible
representation of what the actual
percentage of events are in your life
because you're you're responding based
on what you most remember that said if I
were to ask you for a story if I was
your friend it's also the store you're
most likely to relate and if you were to
think back on the last event when trying
to decide what you're doing next it's a
something you might think of or remember
so it's kind of a positioning
this work in that regards I can't tell
you what percentage of people in what
percentage of time actually do reviewing
I can tell you from the tone of the
stories that we I know the percentage of
people who responded about it Mike even
had a cheat sheet okay I can't find him
ask me later and I will give you the
actual percentage because we asked
people in the follow-up survey for the
first story whether or not they had
researched we didn't even just wait for
them to respond here on when they're
talking about things they don't always
discuss it more frequently say oh I
heard or oh I saw or I went to go check
this out or I glanced these sorts of
reviews when I say research I mean it
very broadly I include like my friend
installed this and told me was awful but
this kind of words it's a little mix of
reputation and things and there are some
things that people were really willing
to spend the time so particularly
jailbroken devices they weren't updating
until the jailbreak was going to work on
the other side of the update and they
were very clear about this so key
features that they really cared about if
there's a particular feature they really
cared about they would go research
before the update there was a lot of
people there were a lot of people that
just updated to see what just because
you're supposed to but for those that
did research these are the things they
were concerned about was it more buggy
is they going to eat more of my battery
I decided that I wasn't going to install
the update because I have heard all the
reviews online about how it generally
makes your phone slower in every respect
so this is a common sort of statement
that I would get in stories is it worth
the bother so here's dogbert the product
designer I created an operating system
that uses eighty percent of your time
begging for updates that still leaves a
healthy twenty percent of your time to
reboot your computer over and over of
course it's boss asked if it also faxes
but this was a common statement so we
hear a lot about you know I hate reboots
I hate all these other sorts of things
but the key undertone that you heard a
lot is this
going to be worth the amount of effort
I'm about to put into it and it does
actually require a fair amount of effort
in some case when considering this they
worry about things like how important is
this software so people understand that
their antivirus is important and they'll
say that they don't think iTunes is
important because they don't use it very
often it might be a comment comment
effort required to do the installation
the risk of the installation the amount
of disruption which is where most three
boots its but sometimes it disrupts in
other sorts of ways so this user hit
most of them I generally do not update
iTunes because I think there are too
many of them and I don't regularly use
the software so I I'm also annoyed by
the fact there's another program update
added to the prompt so I have to uncheck
it since it downloads junk software onto
my computer otherwise quite a jumbo it
is also less people job is fascinating
because Java just switched Java used to
install the ask toolbar which Microsoft
now consider some versions of which to
be a virus and removes it and as just
switched to now altering your default
search engine to yahoo and I will get
back to that in a moment because it is
such an exciting topic resources
resources were a serious concern
particularly in terms of delaying so if
we want to talk about why users to play
and someone mentioned it earlier that
even windows itself respects the battery
life and will attempt to delay an update
until that resource is available so we
see things like okay there's a download
coming so I better backup stuff before I
even try this because it eats all my
drive space particularly if I'm on a
budget device like an iPhone to get a
budget end of an iphone and this is also
an issue with data plan limits so it
actually costs a lot of money for me to
get this update down on to my device
gets even more fun when my device isn't
mobile so I have some users talk about
how they have to visit the library or
some other public place in order to get
the Wi-Fi necessary to pull down the
updates on their mobile devices and then
and I have a couple stories about a
devices such as xbox so this isn't ps2's
that aren't connected to the internet
because they don't have internet home so
these whole epic stories about how this
person went to the friends house
downloaded an update on to a USB Drive
went back to their house plugged it in
it didn't work for some reason and then
somewhere in the middle of this whole
process gave up decided wasn't me that
important of an update and so for non
mobile devices which advises that can't
be moved on to one of these locations we
see long delays these sorts of things so
I first had to delete half the apps on
my phone and I also uploaded my pictures
to my computer and delete them off of my
phone because I didn't have enough usage
to install the update iPhone user common
problem researchers are also a major
issue while installing the update this
is where we hid battery power processing
power locked out of using devices so it
costs processing power some of these
devices are overloaded at the any given
moment so if i install an update in the
background you assume that oh they must
have that much background processor free
I've several users that basically
explained how their system just
mysteriously came to a crawl and they
couldn't figure out what to do about the
situation until they finally figured out
that Windows Update was doing this and
so they went into the update settings
and changed them to notify because it
was not worth delay to their job that
this was causing because even though it
was a background update their system was
too Laden to handle a background update
Windows Update drains my processing
resources preventing backups and even
stopping me from running stat software
for my job so this type of thing
happened and not just for windows okay
so now we're going to get back to your
comment a little bit updates contain
viruses this is not a large percentage
of my story data set but is such an
interesting percentage we'll talk about
it we're also talking about it because
when I present this to undergrads not
this research specifically but how to be
safe online I get this question from
some random member of the audience oh
but I heard update since involve viruses
and this happens to me often enough
but this slide is now up here I honestly
could not tell if it was trustworthy I
did not know if I should accept it or
not I chose not and it was a wise choice
as a friend told me later that it was a
virus I have no idea how this friend
would know this I'm betting you that the
person described something that looked
like it came off the internet and the
friend just decided that things off the
internet or bad became very hesitant and
did not install windows update due to a
virus that exploded windows update and
allowed it and proper code to be signed
to Microsoft certificates this resulted
in multiple rootkit virus that was
compromised by the system if I remember
correctly this was a particular one off
news article that went out but this user
actually absorbed that data and solve
that problem by turning off windows
update because it's dangerous and
updates contain viruses alright so we
have that problem with just a general
problem but it's actually being
conflated a lot by the bundled software
affairs fairness they're not exactly
looking for yet to hear that some social
engineering attacks do in fact pretend
to be update like you are to be bit you
know that they put up is update like you
guys in this section excellent way to
get to drop wineries in the system it's
actually worse than that um so if you
look at Adobe art not go beyond Android
particularly I'm a one-off developer in
Android i made this shiny new flashlight
app that's actually respecting your
privacy by the way flashlight apps are
insanely dangerous on android don't
install them but i've made a new one you
really like it I've got a whole pile of
users and so some company comes in and
says oh i'll offer you six thousand
dollars for this app and you're like oh
pay dirt and so you you hand over the
credentials you get your six thousand
dollars and they install malware on that
many devices overnight with no warning
and in that regard yeah we're looking at
combination of it's not clear when
something is or is not a valid update i
had several the stories feature a
situation which an update pop
up they closed it and then they went and
found the homepage and installed it
we're looking at em Turk users there a
little bit more nervous about these
things but again we're looking at those
sorts of channel attacks and while this
may be a one-off news article it's did
happen I've been told by security
professionals that actually one of the
fun things to attack is Wireshark if you
can break into the Wireshark update
chain oh boy those are fun computers a
wire shark is a network analysis tool
it's used almost entirely by system
administrator type people the people
that have the better credentials to
steal all right so bundled software this
is interesting so in case you don't know
what bundled soccer is this is the best
example I could find for you flash would
love it if you also installed the mcafee
security plus tool this is some people
describe this as a blocking problem for
them not because it's impossible to
uncheck these boxes but because if you
screw up you end up wasting several
hours of your life undoing the problem
and because of that even though this is
a low effort it's high risk and so if
you don't see a good reason to do it I
taught some people are like I just don't
even try because if I did it's just not
worth it and so they delay it or they
just don't update at all but it gets a
little bit better so the update for
QuickTime gave me problems because it
comes with an add-on software some of
the software has viruses and can harm
the computer it also has redirects and
takes over search engines I decide not
to update from them unless I really need
it so if you think about what a virus
looks like to an average end user what
did viruses do they put up pop-ups they
change your search engine they change
your home page this is the sort of
behavior of a virus I had a informatics
professor show up in my office right
after Mozilla decided to change the
default search engine to Yahoo because
he was desperately concerned he had a
virus on his machine why viruses do
things like that and so well you're
actually seeing
keeley with Java as it was brought up
earlier when you see things that uh were
updates or emulating virus type activity
it's actually causing a learning
feedback loop to some degree for end
users that oops I install the virus
that's what a virus looks like these
things contain viruses and you start
ending with up with that particular
painting that's it thankfully I didn't
actually see that many stories that
cover this but as I said a surprising
number of undergrads are concerned about
it so it's interesting so what can we do
out of this one interesting question is
how do we support things like review
behavior so people are really interested
in going out and finding information
about these updates what can we do to
either support them finding of
information by presenting information
that's more interesting or supporting
them through providing more feedback to
the reviews so if you look at reviews
for updates they're actually pretty
minimal compared to say something like
what you see on Amazon or any of these
other sites that do reviewing it would
be nice if we can actually provide some
accurate real-time information to users
I know we can't tell upfront whether or
not an update will reboot your machine
because we don't know what will be in
memory at the time of the installation
it'd be nice if I knew before I hit the
Update button if I'm going to need to
reboot my machine it also be nice to
know of how much I actually use
something there are a lot of clients
eyes statistics that might be very
assistive to an end user when they're
attempting to make these decisions this
is almost impossible problem but how do
we clarify which updates are actually
updates in which of them are actually
viruses or malicious it'd be interesting
to see a discussion of workflows I see
some users who talk about oh I really
want to get use a software right now and
then I see other users are like yeah I
really need to use that software right
now so I minimize the update window and
when I finished using the software I hit
the button to update I have seen very
few interfaces that actually allow
options such as installed us as soon as
I am finish in both the studies you
describe you don't look at the temporal
characteristics
when people are updating and i wondered
i think i'll be home very revealing
about when would be the best time to
there's actually a good question i'm
trying to think if i did look at any of
that in the data i did ask people where
they were physically located and how
busy they were but i wasn't really
seeing any good correlations between
that and some of the contents of the
stories the biggest problem is that when
i asked for story type data as stories
usually encompass multiple updates over
a long time frame to form a full and
cohesive story and so some of the
questions about like where were you did
really make sense to end users which is
why i haven't really dealt with that
data and the little bit of what I've
been talking about a lot of people will
delay till they have a moment but I
can't quantify what that is at the
moment so it's an interesting question
certain things are best done in the dark
you know so I mean the latest mac OS
think is basically do the switch there's
due to light in the moral kind of thing
and I think they kind of go and sense
when you're not using the machine to
figure out one tonight is for you and
then on the windows side it's a
four-hour window which is pretty far out
and oftentimes pushes you into nighttime
anyhow so I mean it's sort of I think
there'll be a spike of those is my
suspicions angry actually might have so
little bit of that data for my 37
subjects but they're also grad students
and when tinnitus might be a little
different point I'm particularly
interested in whether you think users
differentiate of different levels of
trust associate with the different
providers yeah I'm not even hesitating I
mean I I don't know if I have quite the
right data state that in a publication
but I would one of the studies i would
like to rhyme as soon as i get a grad
student to run it would look huh where
are we where are we you're actually not
doing too bad so if you look at from an
air bars perspective apple's sitting
around here ranging from oh thank god
I've been wanting that new shiny thing
to Apple screws
everything up wants me to buy a new
device and I never update their stuff
Microsoft is kind of sitting in the in
bama ambivalent midi middle people hate
the reboots this is not news but broadly
they don't seem to find the updates to
be that problematic but one of the big
reasons they don't is that you provide
an ability to revert so the tone here is
a little bit that there's a safety net
when things go wrong so what happens and
you see this in stories particularly
ones featuring a Microsoft Update
failure so what will happen is that
they'll try to update something will go
horribly wrong they'll describe how
horrible it was and then they'll explain
that they just reverted the system and
didn't update for the next week users
also have a lot of faith in company's
ability to work out bugs so the strong
differentiation between they think the
company put in there on purpose and what
they think the company put in there on
accident so if they think they put the
company put that in by accident then
their reaction to something negative
online is oh I'm going to wait a couple
days because they have faith that
developers will fix those sorts of
problems if they think that Apple
purposefully turned off the support for
their first generation ipod they don't
think that they're going to sort that
out and as a result they just disable
all the updates the the build trust is
an interesting thing because you I very
rarely do I see statements like updates
just cause problems usually I see
statements like Java is awful or
Microsoft picks the worst times for
rebooting my computer they're almost all
prepended with a statement from a
particular company or a particular
software brand they seem to have a very
strong now what I'm not sure is if that
carries through into the app type model
I saw a little bit of that naps but it's
not strong enough usually I'll see
things like Oh app updates on my iPhone
are fine they'll particularly call it
the iphone but they won't necessarily
pull out and I don't know
focusing Communitech sure I mean like
rage and followed that is great but does
it actually affect thanks so like can
you line it up with the stock price or
something I mean in the case of Adobe
more seriously though in the last year
alone we've seen so many CDs release
that are in the poor company frankly is
in the gutter Jabbar is not a boon for
Oracle of this point at all I mean I
think we are probably doing okay on that
front at least down in that like 99 2000
that was a different story but my sense
is that those so smaller if you were
like in the case of Adobe especially
companies do bear the brunt of a lot of
this negativity to a point where it's
like a measurable effect there's a very
interesting presentation by the person
Adobe in charge of update at said ha
whatever the OP date workshop is and I'm
spacing on the name of it hasn't run for
a couple years in which he tried to
explain why it was Adobe wasn't
automatically updating because you think
that this would solve the problem if we
just automatically updated it's a really
interesting talk that he gives because
when his primary reasons actually legal
in a lot of countries it's illegal to
just reach into someone's computer
change the code without telling them
they call that hacking and so the there
was a deep concern initially before
Microsoft started really testing these
waters about the safety for a company
about going and pushing these automatic
updates out and so if you look at who
started doing the automatic updating
first it had less to do with like you
know who is innovative about this
concept and more to do with who had
enough lawyers to back up the problem
and so you look at it right Microsoft's
did this first and they did it much like
they they kind of put their toe in to
some degree air until all the way now we
hit Windows 10 where you can't turn it
off if you're a home user and I'm
fascinated to see how that turns out to
like Google try it next and then we
didn't even c java doing this to like
two or three years ago you think java is
the most invisible thing to our users
the smartest thing to automatic update
in many cases
unless you're on a corporate network or
a couple things but most of those people
know to turn off the updates for their
devices but they weren't willing to do
it and Adobe wasn't willing to do it
because they were concerned about the
legal implications so now we're seeing
Adobe which middle II has enormous no
problems starting to push the automatic
route for a long time Adobe actually had
this policy if you read their
documentation where they would
automatically download the update and
then wait 30 days before it wouldn't
automatically install it so if you
didn't get around to installing it for
30 days it would auto install because
they were trying to provide the most
amount of notification to an end user so
it's kind of a roundabout answer to your
question um so something to do this
stuff needs to happen horrible property
this boot sequence in order to pre cash
some stuff the consequence of this was
that if you install the adobe update it
was essential if you had to reboot
immediately your Windows computer and so
this 30-day delay thing a lot of what
they were doing basically was hoping
that you would reboot your computer for
some other reason within those 30 days
at which point they would grab it I know
that that's actually very interesting
thank you I didn't know that one um I
will the other part of his talk that I
thought was just kind of hilarious is
apparently they had some security hole
they patched it they pushed it out he
described it as waiting for the other
shoe to drop for someone to finally
start exploiting this and then he got a
phone call from one of their data
centers who was according to them almost
experiencing a ddos level attack on this
particular update patch and it turned
out that someone had used it to steal
world of warcraft players accounts and
so people were actually driving home
from work to patch this piece of
software because it was like the patch
was out on all the forums like you
better do this right now it took him a
lot of figure that but he never had a
DDOT level attack on is like on the
update channel before so it's kind of
interesting okay anyway so one of the
outcomes it's not quite there that I'd
like to take this work
is how do we communicate what's actually
happening an update to and end users and
I like to think of this as kind of like
the the five questions so if we were to
answer five questions on every update
interface what should they be what what
information is most important to an end
user to know and if we were to do
something like a review website like I
see review websites for clothing they
ask things like was this the size it
claimed to be was this the color it
claimed to be uh or if you go on to
travel website was the hotel clean like
what are those standard questions and so
one of the things I'm trying to pull out
is what those questions should be and
this is an initial attempted I but from
the resource downloads like how big is
this upload as this download file like
how many resources is how much resources
will it take to install how long will
this update take to install on my
computer I realize that's a very
challenging question to answer what one
of the worst things I saw from people
was we tried to code for how long the
updates were taking which totally failed
because some people think 10 minutes way
too long and some people think 30
minutes is just fine but the thing that
made it most negative was when it was
outside of their expectations so I don't
mean an accurate prediction I mean a
ballpark how long am I going to be tied
down to this one spot that has wireless
is it going to be an hour is it going to
be two hours is going to be 10 minutes
will a reboot be needed like how much
basically how much of a bother is this
going to be to me well this is this a
silent update so a lot of the security
updates are effectively silent right
they don't change anything is this going
to change anything I see and how will
this update impact performance and that
last question is the one that they are
least likely to believe from the
developer but might be really
interesting to see on a review site on
how people are viewing the performance
changes up or down um yeah so going
forward him I thought maybe we know so
much about the computer I mean we go so
many logs and Microsoft with the vendor
together that kind of stance you think
you could have a predictive model of
that but one of the things that would be
really fascinating to take is the next
step here is to just go and create a
variation of the Wix installer where you
just create a on of the woods installer
be enough but try to take one of the
common pieces of installation code Wix
being an example of that and try to
build in the answers to some of these
sorts of questions so this might be a
little bit too much for wickes to figure
out but you're right I'm like I don't
know why we don't look at how to do this
and maybe someone does and I just
haven't made the connection yet but
these are the serious concerns that
honestly I can't ask a developer I can't
say you know can you tell me how long
this will take thanh this arbitrary
person's computer we don't necessarily
know some of the computers are horribly
lady yeah that's a good one I've heard
that one a lot by the way the revert
capability on Windows is heavily used
not just for Windows updates also asked
prior to choosing to update but also
there must be things that we can deliver
to the user post post up in like like
the empty to revert or other kinds of
feedback about what's just happened
maybe highlighting things that are not
different or you know giving these are
more sir richer information at that
point so there was a /a a big thread
which take that with a grain of salt um
basically complaining you know I had
this appt yesterday it's not working
today what do I do about this kind of
ash / thing in this long complained
thread which I actually read through
which I tried to not normally do a
slashdot but it was really interesting
because reverting was one of the top
things on the complaints I had this appt
yesterday why can't I just go back to
the way it was working yesterday and
there was in some cases that's possible
but we're starting to see a lot more
situations with servers right so my app
doesn't work in isolation it works in
relation to this API and so both of
those things need to be functioning and
one of them will just stop supporting
the situation
after a while and so it is interesting
to ask whether or not reverting is
possible through the app and maybe even
a way to inform a user what the time of
life is of their current one so I meet a
lot of professors actually that have
disabled updates for the length of the
semester and then tell me that they just
their computer just does all of that
about two weeks after the grades are due
because I can't afford everything going
wrong during the semester they're way
too busy and so there's this little bit
of gap of like people okay I just need
to put it off for a while well how long
can you actually put this off before you
start seeing maybe non security level
problems with the app or the API but
this is pretty much all my talk the next
slide after the next one is the
questions one so if we have questions
it's fun actually I think I've gone
through everything with that so we're at
the questions but I'm going to go back
to the slides we seem to be more
interested in it so any other questions
um I mean it seems like asking users
about some of these features if you will
while it's valuable it has almost no way
to get at the part of the methods of a
speaker which is the benefit of the
update which is largely invisible Sasuke
looks like asking the patient well do
you like is that that they'll say oh
they are wonderful bedside manner and
there are offices are clean and they
gave me a lollipop which is great but it
doesn't tell you you think about the
actual quality of service when when it
is spotted the problem will save their
life right so can we get the deeper
level here by asking you this question
so is that out of there we have to
remember users are in both ends of the
sub day one user is the one consuming
the update but one of them is generating
it so if you think of it if software
developers I think of them as user
sometimes but they're different style of
user so the the result of this research
kind of goes in both of those directions
so on one hand how do we phrase this to
an end user such that they're more like
they want it but on the other hand what
is it the end users are worrying about
can be translated backwards I'll give
you an example actually from itunes
so we the first study I did we it takes
a long time to interview people so the
length of this interview process is
about a month and a half itunes
helpfully released an update with a
massive user interface change on like
right before our initial interviews and
then a month and a half later you know
we finish our interviews so it turns out
what they done is they released a patch
that was 160 some security
vulnerabilities and they had done it
about two weeks before they released the
major you eye patch so when I interview
people all of them had installed the
security updates no problems at all the
UI updates for the first batch of users
they were terrified one user described
it as oh my god where'd my music go I
went back up and you know I blocked
everything I told all my friends to
block everything a month and a half
later the sentences I was hearing or a
little different there were closer to I
saw my friend using this I now feel like
I know how to interact with it itunes
had gone and switched between a sidebar
interviews to a modal interface which
the major you i changed and so some
users didn't even know how to access
their music right off so watching
watching their friends interact with it
kind of made them feel more comfortable
about it and then by the end of the
interviews i was like well you know it
didn't look too bad i installed it I've
reactivated it I bought a new iphone
that requires me to have the latest one
so I've installed it when you're looking
at large changes that aren't bug base
the more like user interface feature
changes there's kind of an adjustment
time period so one of the ways you can
adapt this towards security is doing
what they did there which is release all
the security updates with a small time
lag users get those installed they have
the gut reaction to the UI change they
kind of get over it as many of them that
are going to and then you start
releasing the security outfit so that's
one way you can take this type of
research and apply it more in the
software engineering direction i'm
thinking more about how you are bundling
the updates and what goes into each
update so if we can take this things we
really want people to install and bundle
them in a separate update from the
things that people really worried about
it's fine is also a point of
advertisement so when you
look at some of these interfaces for
updates you kind of see a bad example of
this but they they kind of are getting
some of these messages they say the
words improve performance they say like
when you're looking at what your app
actually does there's certain things you
can pull out and say okay what is it the
users really care about here well I put
our performance app that also happens to
have the security thing and users are
more likely to pay attention to that
that's worth the bother so there's a
little bit of marketing there there's
some really almost no research and how
to explain that this is security update
and get users to care about it because
it's invisible the only example i have
is somebody who decided to create an
application on windows that puts
graffiti on the screen slowly as the
apps on the device gets older but um
well fun I don't think that's
necessarily going to work for most users
so I don't actually have a good answer
for this I'm kind of working on it as
part of the answer and the other part is
this sentence I hear from users which is
I installed this thing nothing changed
was it really worth the risk so we need
some way to communicate that something
changed or we need to communicate what
other risk you just countered like I
would love to see a study in which we
just took the most recent news article
from someplace and said this is what
it's countering if you want to be safe
from this problem this thing that just
showed up in the New York Times that's
what this update does and I don't know
what that would do but it would be an
interesting study you the update does he
you need to know that there was
something very plain nothing changes
just saying TQ in a way hopefully
Microsoft is somewhat unique in that you
allow multiple update channels it's
possible to install security updates
without installing other updates that's
rare most updates are cumulative so you
at the moment they block the UI update
they've blocked everything it's not just
the security update people also tend to
be a bit more improvement so this is
where we
back to trust so if you are actually
doing what you say then you just have no
problems with even the iTunes where they
have strong opinions about iTunes they
will happily install the security update
so that's the slightest bit of concern
because apples managed to convince them
that the security updates don't screw
things up or when they do they
immediately fix it again we forgive bugs
some degree so if you can convince you
user that your security updates will
actually not mess anything up and you
build that trust relationship then yeah
you should just push them silently and
it totally works there's usually
something I say here about disabled
users so I've interviewed one blind user
that was explaining to me how every
update on hermas whole machine is turned
off because she loses the ability to
even fix the machine if it updates and
it messes up her screen reader so she
needs to select very specific times
either when her screen reader software
approves the update or when she's in the
presence of someone who can assist her
with the fixing of the machine if
something goes wrong because it's a very
serious problem so it's kind of this
mashup between yeah automatic updates if
we can do them safely and quietly and
silently go ahead we should get them
away from users but we do need a little
bit of catch in there for some of these
other groups that do need it but it's
not the maker all right any other
questions
you